let's look just squarely at the science  and the science says we are all innately  Spiritual Beings  with or without the Embrace of religion  we're all born with the spiritual core  there's no reason that the scientific  lens has to be limited to  interpretations or understandings that  are simply I don't mean materialistic  although that can come of material but  material only that which we can touch  which we can point to I literally have  friends who are scientists who say that  because you've shown the neural  correlates of spirituality in the brain  we now know spirituality is real Griff  physical fitness for the physical core  we need spiritual Fitness for the  spiritual court and if we build the  spiritual core we are 80 less likely to  be addicted 60 percent less likely to  take our lives we're able to be whole  and Thrive we have disintegrated the  spiritual core from the rest of the  person and disintegration is unhealth